مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجزيلنباء من قناه
الجزيره اعلنت وزاره الصحه السوريه سقوطها
خمسه قتلى بينهم معسكري وخمسه عشر اصابه
بينهم حالات حرجه في القصف الاسرائيلي على
احياء سكنيه في دمشق وكانت وكاله العلماء
السوريه قالت ان صواريخ اسرائيليه اصابت
ابنيه ماهوله في منطقه كفر سوسه وتحدثت
الوكاله عن تصدي وسائل الدفاع الجوي
لاهداف المعاديه في سماء العاصمه في ساعه
متاخره من مساء امس السبت
نقلت رويترز عن مركزي رصدي الزلازل الاورو
متوسط ان زلزالا بقوه
5.2 هزا منطقه وسط تركيا امس السبت وتمكنت
فرق الانقاذ في ولايتها تاي التركيه من
انقاذ شخصين احدهما طفل من تحت الانقاض
بعد مرور 13 يوما من وقوع الزلزال وكانت
السلطات اعدلت ارتفاع عدد القتلين نحو 40
الفا
وفي سوريا قالت وحده تنسيق الدعم التابعه
للالتلاف السوري المعارض ان اكثر من 55
الف شخص نزحوا الى الملاجئ بعد الزلزال
طردت تونس الامينه العامه الامينه العامه
للاتحاد النقابات الاوروبيه بسبب مشاركتها
في احتجاج النقبي وذكر قرار لرئاسه تونسيه
نترضى
بسبب التدخل السافر في اشياء الداخلي
وادانا المتحدث باسم الاتحاد العام
التونسيل الشغل سامي الطاهري قرر السلطات
التونسيه ترحيل الامين العامه لاتحاد
النقابات الاوروبيه ستارلينش واعتبر
الطاهري قراره هذا القرار اعتبره وصمه لا
يشرف تونس
هذا ونظمه الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
سلسله تحركات وتجمعات عماليه في صفاقس هو
عدد من الولايات عقب ملاحقات قضائيه
استهدفت عددا من النقابيين وقال الاتحاد
انه لن يساوم على حقوق التونسيين في
العيشيه بكرامه
اشتدت تحده المعارك في محيط مدينه باخموت
الاستراتيجيه في اقليم دوباس الشرقيه
اوكرانيا وقال مؤسس ميليشيا فاغنر الروسيه
انه تمت السيطره على بلده باراسكا الواقعه
شمال مدينه بخموت
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان بلاده لا تريد
الصراعا مع بجين وانها لا تسعى لحرب بارده
جديده معها لكنها ستدافع دون اعتذار عن
قيمها ومصالحها وحذر يمكن ان نظيره
الصينيه على هامشي مؤتمر للامن من
تداعياته وعواقب تقديم الصين دعما ماديا
لروسيا او مساعدتها في التهرب من العقوبات
انتهى الموجود